Trascrizione: Viviana Calmasini
Revisore: Stefania Recchia
Scusate per l'attesa
La vida es una tombola de noce e de dia.
Lo si potrebbe dire con le parole di Manu Chao
che dice che la vita è una tombola
di notte e di giorno
oppure si potrebbe pensare
quando Forrest Gump ci dice
candidamente:
"La vita è come una scatola di cioccolatini
non sai mai quello che ti capita".
Ecco, dentro queste due citazioni
quello che ci trovo io
che mi appartiene
che penso appartenga a tutti noi
è dunque l'imprevedibilità della vita,
il fatto che ci possa sempre essere qualcosa
che non c'aspettavamo
che non avevamo previsto.
E vi sarete chiesti
perchè questa ragazza entra
con queste tre palline
Io non sono una circense
anche se in realtà non mi dispiacerebbe
ma quello che per me rappresentano
queste tre palline
un po' metaforicamente
è il circolo della vita
e quindi
sapete
è facile farne girare due,
lo farebbe anche un bambino!
E chissà quante volte
ve le han fatte girare anche a voi
però
è proprio
secondo me è proprio la terza
che rende le cose più difficili,
e dunque, più interessanti
Ecco, quello che è successo a me
all'età di diciotto anni
è stato un qualcosa di imprevisto,
una variabile x
che non m'aspettavo
Ecco, io stavo tranquillamente vivendo
la mia vita
quando all'improvviso
la mia terza pallina è caduta
Che cosa è successo?
Stavo tornando da una festa
allegra, felice, spensierata
di notte
e un pirata della strada
ha deciso proprio in quella sera
proprio in quel momento
di portarmi via metà della mia gamba sinistra,
e con questo si è portato via
le mie speranze di futura pallavolista
si è portato via la spensieratezza
di quegli anni
di uscire con le amiche a fare festa
sui tacchi alti
senza pensare troppo
a che cosa significhi fare le scale
a che cosa significhi avere due gambe intere.
Io fino a quel momento non sapevo
che cosa significasse la fortuna di avere due gambe
la fortuna di avere la salute
e provate a immaginarvi
quanto possa essere stata dura
ritrovarsi a essere disabile
a diciotto anni
a dover prendere il cartellino per la macchina
perchè sei disabile e ti spetta
però è una cosa che al cuore fa male
Immaginatevi essere in ospedale
e non riuscire a muoversi
a lavarsi da soli.
Ricordo, quello è stato proprio
il fondo per me.
E da quel fondo
quando ero lì
ho pensato dentro di me:
verranno momenti migliori
e dunque la vita era lì ad aspettarmi
la posta in gioco era troppo alta, troppo
a diciotto anni tu devi esplodere
non puoi stare a piangere sul divano.
E quindi quello che
(Applausi)
e quindi quello che potevo fare
era solo piegarmi,
raccogliere la terza pallina
e ricominciare a vivere
in un modo
un po' diverso.
Grazie, troppo gentili.
In un modo un po' diverso,
nel senso che le cose erano cambiate
adesso non avevo più mezza gamba
ma in realtà avevo tutto tranne mezza gamba
quindi mi sono messa la mia protesi
e ho ricominciato a fare tutto:
andare a ballare in discoteca,
girare le città,
fare forse anche di più
di quello che facevo prima
perchè era come se si fossero abbattute certe barriere,
certi freni inibitori che ti fanno sentire male
o a disagio.
Io ero fatta così.
Dopo un po' ho pensato
o mi prendete così per come sono
oppure non mi prendete
ma io continuo a correre lo stesso
E a proposito della corsa,
una volta raggiunta la normalità
che tanto sognavo in quegli anni,
perché mi son sentita diversa,
ed è brutto sentirsi diversi,
sentire che quando entri in un locale
c'hai tutti gli occhi addosso
e ti fanno male,
e non pensi che magari ti stiano guardando
perchè sei carina,
ma pensi che stiano guardando solo
la tua disabilità e non te come persona.
E quello che è arrivato
dopo un paio d'anni dal mio incidente
e che ha completato
diciamo, la mia risalita verso il milione,
la mia risalita verso la normalità
e la felicità in sostanza,
è stato il ritorno della mia passione
cioè lo sport
Ecco, io prima facevo pallavolo
e poi ho deciso che volevo tornare a correre
avevo perso troppi pullman
per un cinque metri
perché non riuscivo a correre
Ecco, non solo per questo
ho voluto tornare a correre
e a provare, a vedere che cosa si provasse ancora
con una protesi
Non è stato facile perchè
le sensazioni sono molto diverse
devi abituare il tuo fisico,
il tuo schema motorio
è un altro
però ce l'ho fatta
mi è piaciuto
e da quel momento lì non ho più smesso.
E grazie allo sport
ho potuto conoscere davvero che cos'è la disabilità
davvero com'è vissuta in tutto il mondo
perchè cominciando a viaggiare ho conosciuto
atleti di tutto il mondo
Australia, Cina, ma anche semplicemente in Europa
Germania, Francia...
E parlando con loro
e vedendo come loro si approcciavano alla disabilità
ho davvero radicato in me
il pensiero che un disabile è prima di tutto
una persona
con sentimenti, passioni, desideri.
È una persona come tutti gli altri
e se vogliamo vedere anche
un valore aggiunto
il fatto che ogni mattina il disabile si sveglia
e deve far fronte a un piccolo problema o grande che sia
e già il fatto che lo riesca a superare
questo fattore secondo me gli conferisce più energia,
più forza.
E in questa mia avventura
una cosa che davvero non mi sarei mai aspettata
era proprio quella di arrivare fino a qui.
Chi se lo aspettava
dal letto di ospedale
di arrivare in uno stadio con ottantamila spettatori
e poi da lì ho iniziato
e non ho più smesso. Scusate.
Mi sono dedicata a provare tutti gli sport
qui abbiamo... sono io ve lo giuro eh!
In uno sport che si chiama ice sledge hockey
fantastico, faticosissimo
che è l'hockey equivalente, seduti praticamente.
Poi qui ho incontrato un ragazzo
non so se l'avete mai visto, un certo Bolt
che era uno dei miei sogni comunque incontrare il campione
qua uno dei tanti premi che mi hanno dato
dopo la vittoria a Londra
qui in una mia esperienza televisiva
con una tivù online
qua che mordo medaglie
perché ormai è diventata una cosa che mi diverte assai
e poi il para snowboard
anche quello bellissimo
e poi ho scalato le torri del Violet quest'estate
anche lì non mi sarei mai aspettata di arrivare fino al cocuzzolo.
(Applausi)
E via dicendo.
E questa è l'ultima esperienza che ho fatto a Sochi
alle para-olimpiadi
dove sono andata come inviata giornalista
e come vedete ogni scusa era buona
per fare foto con gli atleti
E dopo tutte queste esperienze
quello che mi sento di dirvi è di provare,
nella vita di tutti i giorni, ad aprire gli occhi
e a vedere che forse la vostra variabile x
per quanto possa essere dolorosa o difficile da superare
ecco magari questa variabile si possa trasformare in qualcosa di bello,
di positivo.
Forse può essere un po' anche l'eccellenza di cui parlava prima Silvia.
E come domanda finale vi chiedo
guardatevi in basso
avete le gambe, tutto a posto
sono lì, accavallate, coi tacchi
poi la testa c'è
e quindi mi sorge spontaneo chiedervi
ma cosa aspettate ad andare a correre?
Siete ancora qui?
Grazie
E ma così mi fate commuovere
Prima di lasciarvi leggo anch'io il mio pensiero
forse vi farà un po' ridere
quello che ho scritto è
"Non tutti i pirati vengono per nuocere"